here is former New Hampshire Governor
Chris sunundo he went on Meet the Press
which is Chuck Todd's Democrat lie
laundering show and sununu who the
machine really wants him and Larry Hogan
to be the republican nominees by the way
I don't know did you see it this morning
Larry Hogan saying he's out
um we've been trying to get him on the
show by the way because I've been
somewhat critical of him because I think
he's he's just sort of become a nothing
liar we've been trying to get him on the
show we haven't heard back on that but
apparently as of I think yesterday or
this morning he's not going to run for
president he was going to get zero
percent which is why the mainstream
media liked him as a republican there's
nothing more than they like then there's
nothing more they like than a loser
Republican the other one is Chris sununo
now I have nothing against this guy he
seems like a perfectly nice guy I think
he's he's probably like a somewhat
decent moderate which means he can't win
so that's why they put him on these
shows but he did a nice job here pushing
back on Chuck tide so Chuck Todd's going
off on Fox News that's what they do
right there's one mainstream channel
that has a counter narrative so they
have to go after Fox and here's Chuck
basic being like and here's sununu
basically being like Chuck you all suck
what do you think Rupert Murdoch and Fox
News need to do to regain some trust
after what we've learned about this and
are you at all concerned you can have an
honest conversation with Fox viewers
oh oh I don't think it's just Fox I I
mean I'll put them in there but all of
media all of Television media and
everyone has to own a little bit uh of
the lack of trust the lack of
accountability it's okay to get
something wrong in the news but you got
to come back and own it and whether it's
fox or CNN or MSNBC or you know whatever
everyone just has to own as a governor I
might try four or five things and if one
or two don't work I'll say hey that
didn't work what about intentionally
lying to viewers we're getting
acknowledge of it we can pass the
funding intentionally lying to viewers
though that that to me seemed to cross
the line
can make a mistake but that's that
wasn't a mistake
so explain to me that look I'm not
defending anybody because I think you're
all you're all in the same basket I
really do but I could go to CNN when
they talk when they they're going to
ignore the the hunter Biden laptop story
we could talk about the virus coming
truly coming out of the lab in Wuhan we
could talk about a lot of different
things if you're not owning that you
misrepresented the story whether it was
intentional or not yeah everybody does
it and that's the problem America is
losing faith in media and you guys have
a huge opportunity to regain that but
right now my message to Fox News is
build your ratings build your audience
go bigger because if we don't go bigger
as a Republican party we can't win in
November so I want them to talk to
Independence more not change our values
or who we are or what we're talking
about as Republicans but get more uh
opportunistic about the chance to bring
more people in Studio seems like a
perfectly nice guy so if I was a little
dismissive of him in the lead in there
like seems perfectly nice I'd be happy
to interview him I don't think he will
have any support really if he runs the
media will kind of push him because
he'll sort of be like an ineffectual
Republican you guys get that how that
whole situation works but he did a
really nice job there the line you're
all in the same bucket that's what he's
saying to Chuck Todd you all lie about
everything and then that Chuck Todd with
a straight face has the gall to be like
well intentionally lying
thank you
[Music]